voici donc ma première question il
n'essaye pas de me rouler je te connais
comme si tu étais moi alors première
question est ce que tu préférerais être
un coq ou un âne un âne j'adore les âmes
et toutes les phoques dudit lemoine je
pense à cette admirable poème de francis
jammes prière pour aller au paradis avec
les âmes lane c'est là martin c'est
toute mon enfance
qu'est ce qu'il ya de plus sexy en toi
ou qu'est ce qu'il y avait pas grand
chose peut-être mon regard je crois pas
donc je crois pas être sexy du tout
qu'est-ce qu'il ya de moins sexy en toi
mon ventre quelles choses négatives
dirais tu sur toi je dirais ce qu'on a
écrit sur mes bulletins scolaires aurait
pu faire mieux
as tu déjà pensé au suicide
oui et à quelles occasions à cause des
modes femmes sont des petits monstres
toujours les bonnes femmes je pense
faire suisse qui a tu le plus envie
d'épater la femme que j'aime
quel est pour toi le signe avant-coureur
de la passion naissante
qu'est ce qu'on appelle le signe
avant-coureur de la passion naissante
c'est le désir ça se traduit comment
chez toi par un besoin d'en faire un peu
trop comme tous les hommes quand as-tu
pleurer pour la dernière fois il ya
trois ans pourquoi toujours la même
chose
34 ans toujours une chose toute façon au
filet par s'y habituer à quel signe
reconnais tu infailliblement la bêtise
qui vous fait qu'elle est appréciée par
le plus grand nombre
quelle est la dernière personne que tu
ais vu envie de tuer le maire de neuilly
quel est pour toi le lieu idéal pour une
étreinte en apportant en imagination ce
qu'en vérité c'est beaucoup plus
confortable dans les endroits prévus
pour ça
le surnom comptes donne et que tu es
bien sûr eh bien j'ai juste
suis jamais arrivé à savoir je pense
qu'on doit m'appeler gros cul et pour
être sûr de ne rien rater de dinars 10
tubes abonnez vous mettez un pouce bleus